les autorités britanniques
s'enorgueillissent de Locus cette
alliance tripartite entre Londres
Canberra et Washington en région de
Pacific qui a rappelé on le fait capoter
la vente de sous-marin français à
l'Australie pour une somme dépassant les
50 milliards d'euros tenter si bien que
Londres se verrait bien adapté ce modèle
à d'autres régions du monde comme
l'article en fait celle des États-Unis
et de l'Australie nous protégeons les
routes maritimes et la stabilité à
travers l'Indo-Pacifique nous
approfondissant notre travail au Canada
pour couvrir des régions comme
l'Arctique et au-delà sa sortie en
réalité dans une tendance qui va se
rapprocher de plus en plus Londres et
Ottawa sur la question arctic car un
autre accord de formation cette fois-ci
entre les forces militaires canadienne
et britannique a été signé en octobre
2021 et tu devrais voir des membres de
la Royal Navy s'entraîner aborder
brise-glace des gardes-côtes canadien un
rapprochement entre autres militaire
entre le Canada et le Royaume-Uni que
n'a pas manqué de souligner l'ambassade
de Russie à Londres
les forces armées britanniques qui
avance agressivement vers de frontière
en Pologne et en Estonie et les
responsables militaire britannique
déclare ouvertement leurs intentions
d'établir une sorte de présence
militaire dans l'Arctique
Moscou de son côté à depuis des années
renforcer sa présence en Arctique en
développant les infrastructures et en
rouvrant des bases militaires parmi les
pays riverains de l'océan glacial la
Russie et probablement le pays qui est
le plus sur le développement de la
région de quoi susciter quelques
curiosité et de fait sur le terrain
n'est constate une présence a cru de
navire aéronef de pays de l'OTAN
les forces navales des États-Unis et des
pays de l'OTAN continue de mener
régulièrement des campagnes individuel
et groupe et de navire de guerre de
surface en mer de Barents nous
constatons une augmentation de la durée
de présence des sous-marins et navires
de surface de l' US Navy en mer de bar
ans et de Norvège
depuis le mois de mai la Russie a sur la
présidence tournante du conseil de
l'Arctique l'opportunité pour elle de
promouvoir tes intérêts dans la région
mais aussi d'appeler la coopération
entre pays membres
et
je propose de revenir à notre
proposition de longue date de
réintroduire la pratique des réunions
régulières entre chef d'état-major des
forces armées des pays membres du
Conseil de l'Arctique
avec la région est déjà une réalité et
n'a pas vocation à apaiser la situation
bien au contraire